Welcome back everyone this will be my full
marvel moon knight episode one video there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs to break down so
if you're brand new to the channel i will be
doing videos for all the episodes just like
i do for all the other disney plus series
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite easter egg from the episode on
the video so careful for spoilers from the episode
if you have not seen moon knight episode 1 i'll
start at the beginning of the episode and we'll
talk about easter eggs wtf moments from everything
as we go along starting with the episode title the
episode was titled the goldfish problem which
is a reference to his changing pet goldfish gus
and steven grant learning about the secret
existence of marc spector like wait a minute
i'm not the real persona like he's slowly learning
about what's actually going on the whole idea in
the comics is that moon knight developed these
alternate personalities when he became moon knight
like he died literally and then was brought back
to life by khonshu to become his avatar on earth
he developed alternate personalities that would
help him infiltrate other aspects of people's
lives and get more information that marc spector
wouldn't be able to otherwise so marc spector is
the original personality he's the mercenary
in the mcu series in the comics there wind up
being at least five different personalities but
on the tv show it looks like they're just doing
two different ones there's steven grant who's
presented as a sort of bumbling idiot shop owner
who is an expert in egyptian mythology and on the
other side of things there's marc spector who's
a mercenary with all these skills and is also
the mooneye persona so when he's in moonlight
persona in the costume he's in full marc spector
personality there's also the mr knight persona
which in the comics is different but the tv show
it seems like it's just going to be another aspect
of the marc spector personality like he'll
still be marc spector when he's mr knight
the actual opening scene of the episode is a
cold open of ethan hawke's villain character
dr arthur harrow who is a deep cut from the comics
even though they've changed a lot of his backstory
you see all the objects that are important to
his character he drinks a glass of water then
shatters the glass and pours it in his shoes just
to be that hardcore i think it's another sly wink
of the comics too in the comics his character is
born with this genetic condition that causes him
to constantly feel pain and he becomes obsessed
with it and starts experimenting on people the
character was also a nazi but he's a relatively
minor character so this whole god-driven plot
with ahmed is something new that they've given
him from the comics the tattoo that shifts his
metal bands around his wrist the crocodile head
walking cane are all meant to be references
to the goddess ammit who is a real character in
egyptian mythology she's referred to as the eater
of the dead the judgment of the scales that they
talk about like the scales that shift on his arm
that's actual god power in the mcu but in
egyptian mythology when someone died the god
of the afterlife anubis would weigh their mortal
soul on a balanced scale against the feather of
mod the goddess of order the people that passed
the test and were deemed virtuous in life would
be lighter than a feather quote unquote they would
be allowed passage into the egyptian underworld
the realm of duat while the rest of them would
be devoured by the goddess ammit if you couldn't
tell she does have the head of a crocodile that's
not an alligator because alligators weren't native
to ancient egypt but she's also meant to have
the hindquarters of a lion the world's original
boogeyman the way the mcu series portrays someone
failing her test of worthiness is her consuming
their souls like the woman turns gray because her
soul is being eaten like she literally just dies
right in front of them the title sequence with the
mcu logo is just the standard marvel phase 4 logo
that we get for all the movies and tv shows maybe
they'll have a custom one later in the series but
this is the same one that you see on most of the
series every once in a while they do get a custom
one though the song that they play underneath
it is just a 60s pop song and it's meant to be
a representation of what's happening in steven
grant's life as he's waking up in the morning
one day if it wasn't clear the series is meant
to pick up after he's already become moon knight
like we see him transform into moonite during the
episode we'll get bits and pieces of his backstory
becoming moon knight how that all happened and
what went down in later flashbacks there are a
couple references to it during the episode like
he's been missing quote unquote for two months
layla wonders where he's been that's a reference
to when he became moon knight for the first time
for the most part the series will take place
between london and in the flashbacks ancient egypt
those will probably go back to egypt when
they try to travel back to the realm of the
gods the pantheon of egyptian gods that khonshu
belongs to are all basically trapped in a pocket
dimension so they're not inside the normal mcu
but he keeps hearing khonshu's voice in his head
he keeps seeing him but it's all happening in his
head khonshu cannot physically manifest in the
world where everybody else could see him but there
are a couple references to that too through dr
arthur harrow's character about his grand mission
like what his whole plan is during the series
if that were to happen all the egyptian gods were
to come into our world physically they would be
way more powerful and just to be clear they're
not really advanced aliens pretending to be gods
they are legit gods in the mcu little g gods not
like the capital g one true god i just did a video
a little while ago about the difference between
gods and really powerful cosmic characters like
the celestials from the eternals movie are one
of the most powerful groups of cosmic characters
most of the other lesser little g gods are not
powerful enough to challenge the celestials so
you can actually be a cosmic character and not
be a god but still be more powerful than the gods
most god's power comes from the faith of their
followers so if more people start worshiping
a god they become more powerful that's why in
present day khanshu does have a lot of power but
most people don't care or know about konshu only
marc spector and a couple other people so even
though he is powerful he's way less powerful than
he used to be when people did worship him but the
opening scene of oscar isaac is of him waking up
as steven grant not understanding anything about
marc spector or moon knight or what's happened
you learn about all these weird things happening
around the house like he's chained to his bed
he's got a circle of sand around the bed he's
got the door taped to see if anybody's come or
gone based on the way they reveal the marc spector
personality later in the episode in his complicity
and all this it sounds like marc spector has tried
to engineer things to make steven forget about who
marc spector is so that he doesn't realize what's
going on part of his arc during the series will
probably be reconciling both of his personalities
and understanding that he needs both steven
grant and the marc spector personality like
they'll start working together more hopefully when
they show his origin story they'll also explain
who the steven grant persona is and how the series
justifies it like if layla didn't know that he
existed any something relatively recent why did
he slip into the steven grant persona in the first
place we see his goldfish for the first time which
is a reference to the title his name gus he's got
the one fin they make a bunch of nemo references
too there are a lot of pop culture references
during the series it winds up being one of the
catalysts for him learning what's going on when
he learns that he's got a different goldfish than
he had before like wait a minute why does it have
two fins now everyone has been criticizing the
weird british accent that he has they even call
it on the episode too the layla character when he
picks up her phone call asks him straight out what
is up with that weird accent you can kind of see
from all the weird things that are happening in
his life as steven grant he's meant to feel like
as different a person and a personality as his
marc spector personality as possible within the
context of the mcu steven grant is a shop owner
at this british museum of history obviously this
is taking place in the england area he understands
things about egyptian history like he gives that
small tour to the little girl he talks about their
culture their customs he has reverence for some
of their artifacts like the pyramids he talks
about what happened to people when they died and
were mummified what happened when their life was
judged in the fields of reeds and how they were
allowed or not allowed to enter the afterlife
all things that happened later in this episode and
in later episodes just in general like that's why
the little girl asked him if it sucked for him
getting rejected from the field of reeds because
it had already happened to him like he literally
died and then was brought back to life by khonshu
after he formed the bargain with him the mummies
and wraps here on the table foreshadow the actual
moonai costume which are basically like egyptian
mummy raps that come around him when he activates
his powers all the different stuffed animals
represent the egyptian pantheon of gods the enya
that he talks about he talks about it having
nine gods instead of seven like there's a big
error on the poster here and the banners in front
of the building the nine egyptian gods that he's
referencing are atom shu teffnet geb nut osiris
isis nephithis and set really cool connection
to thor love and thunder bast the panther goddess
who is worshipped by the panther tribe the group
of people that black panther's ancestors come from
who they derive their power from is also conscious
sister in the mcu in fact the reason why you see
bast is the panther goddess in this lineup here
is because in the current version of marvel comics
she is part of the ineod that the roster changes a
little bit over time so the mcu version is going
to be a little bit different from the comic book
version konshu is actually the son of the leader
of their pantheon at the moment atum who's also
known as amin ra like atum is meant to be the sun
god khonshu is the egyptian god of the moon but in
the mcu khonshu is also the god of vengeance which
is the main reason why he forms the bargain with
marc spector to become his avatar khonshu finds
out what ammit the other goddess is planning and
he wants to stop her then he has that longer
funny scene talking to the statue about this
weird alternate life just kind of hinting at the
idea of marc spector before he's learned about him
the leaf that blows on the water as he's walking
away is also meant to be a reference to egyptian
mythology in the goddess of myth and some of the
things that were associated with her character
all meant to foreshadow the arthur harrow
twist later when he starts talking about her
when he goes back home and the recording starts
speaking to him trying to help him stay awake
all these different techniques they do a montage
of him learning more about egyptian history he
starts reading about this quote-unquote hidden
god like the one true god of egypt at one point
that's a reference to when the pharaoh at the time
abolished worship of the old pantheon and told
everybody to worship this one god and it's one
of the first examples in the world of monotheism
then when he starts playing with the rubik's cube
he throws it up but when he catches it back down
he actually wakes up in the field after a big
time jump so if it wasn't clear what's happening
here this is all time moving forward and he's
just slipping between different personalities
like he's gone to sleep and switched into his
alternate marc spector persona and during all the
missing time that we've seen he's actually gone
to germany to steal the scarab beetle and tried
to escape the reason why he wakes up in the field
of grass here in germany with the people shooting
him out the window is because he literally
just jumped out the window and hurt his jaw
on the fall but the thing is is the impact of him
hitting the ground caused him to switch back to
the steven grant persona which is why he's still
speaking with steven grant's voice like wait a
minute how i get here what's going on they kind
of play it that way the rest of the episode there
are several time jumps and each time you always
wake up as the steven grant persona after marc
spector has done something crazy but we do see
khonshu for the first time and hear him speak it's
f murray abraham solieri himself he's been in a
billion different things so you remember him from
somewhere but it'll be a lot of fun to hear him
yelling in his ear this whole time yelling at both
of them like if you both fail he gets the scare
beetle back i'll kill both of you the whole idea
with khonshu is that he's not a good god he's very
capricious he switches his mood on a dime and he
really only cares about himself but he does try to
do good things but you have to remember he doesn't
really care about humanity that much during this
series he's really just trying to prevent ammit
from entering the world and killing a whole bunch
of people the whole idea with the scarab beetle as
you've seen in the trailer footage is that it acts
as sort of like a god tier compass and it sounds
like they're going to be using it to help them
find the entrance to the realm of the gods like
arthur harrow talks about wanting ammit to exist
physically in our mcu dimension it sounds like the
scarab beetle is going to help him do that they
have a much longer scene with ethan hawke's arthur
harrow character who seems a little bit confused
about what's going on with steven grant like
okay give me the scarab beetle back but he doesn't
yet realize that he's not talking to marc spector
they show him using ammit's power for the first
time they weigh a couple different people just
to show you what happens to people who are good
and people who are evil people who fail the test
like i said if you fail the test she consumes your
soul she basically just sucks it right out of your
body they're using a very bloodless method to show
it on screen i think what'll happen in the series
is that we'll physically see her eventually in
cg and we'll see a version of her like actually
eating someone when he identifies marc spector as
a mercenary give me the scare of mercenary that's
just a comic book reference because marc spector
was a mercenary before he became moon knight when
he tries to give him the scarab but then closes
his fist that's also meant to be a sly wink at
him being called the fist of khonshu in the comics
but it's also a reference to khonshu controlling
his body physically so remember he died and then
agreed to become khonshu's avatar and execute his
will on earth so khonshu brought him back to life
when that happened it formed a bond between them
it also gave khanu control of his body so khonshu
can actually take over his body if he wants to at
certain times after he gets mobbed as steven
grant he passes out again there's another time
jump switching to marc spector and wakes up as
steven grant after having just beat the crap out
of a bunch of people he steals the cupcake truck
which you can see now clearly does not say von
doom when the first trailer dropped there were
so many comments about this on my video is this
von doom does this mean doctor doom is coming
to the mcu just like i said on that video just
like i'm saying now no it is not a doctor doom
reference but he will eventually come to the mcu
in some other form they play the george michael
song wake me up as steven grant tries to escape
which is meant to be commentary on the action like
steven grant is hoping that he wakes up from this
nightmare and also wakes up later in the steven
grant persona i'll talk about that in a second too
but it's also a reference to khonshu yelling
in his ear about going to sleep so that marc
spector can wake up and take over so that they
can accomplish what it is that khonshu wants
him to do there's another small time jump where
he wakes up with the gun in his hand he's taking
care of some of the attackers but not everybody
the truck stops because it runs out of fuel but
then he's barely saved by the falling lumber from
higher up on the hill you also notice during all
these different action scenes in the time jumps
that the different henchmen all have the scale
tattoos on their arms as do the other people later
in the episode they probably have something to
do with arthur harrow being able to control them
using ahmed's power it's sort of like the show's
version of a hail hydra kind of moment like we
are amongst you everywhere we've infiltrated
all of society and you're only learning about it
now but then he slips back between personalities
and when he wakes up again it's in his bed
chained just like he did when he went to sleep
and the reason why he starts laughing and crying
is because he mistakenly believes that it was all
just a bad dream when really a couple days have
gone by which they use the goldfish like the title
implies the goldfish problem when he learns that
the goldfish is different and then he goes to the
dinner to have the steak dinner with the woman
but finds out it's a couple days later than it's
supposed to be after he does figure the date out
he starts finding marc spector's hidden belongings
the cell phone the key to the storage locker with
all of his weapons and his mercenary gear that
we'll see probably an episode too he sees the
missed calls are from layla his love interests
she's an archaeologist that will meet an episode
too as well she's sort of a combination of the
marlene character with a couple other characters
in the comics she says it's been two months since
she's learned about what happened to him and she
doesn't know steven grant is that's why i say that
steven grant persona is probably something new
that happened after he became moon knight for the
first time and it's been about two months since
he became moon knight if you're a longtime moon
knight comic book reader you also recognize the
duchamp name on his phone that person is frenchy
from the comics he's sort of his partner as a
mercenary and his pilot he flies him around helps
him get whatever it is that he needs whatever
weapons then when he stares in the mirror and
he starts trying to figure everything out things
start shaking he actually sees a reflection of
marc spector speaking to him even though it's
kind of dark you don't really see it until later
in the episode when he's in the bathroom but it's
marc spector's voice speaking to him telling him
to stop you're going to get yourself in trouble
when they have the scene of khonshu coming to him
in the elevator like he's physically moving
towards him it's actually just happening in his
head like he tells the old woman oh i'm looking
for my contact lens on the floor the old woman
is real she just can't see khonshu because it's
happening in his head there is a bit of a flaming
skull easter egg over here in the graffiti
you could call that a ghostwriter reference
because moonite and ghostwriter are both members
of the midnight suns team it sounds like they're
using the moon knight series in the werewolf by
night series the blade movie kit harrington and
the eternals movie to sort of set up a darker team
up in the mcu so it sounds like eventually we'll
see a version of that happen they have another
time jump as he switches between personalities and
wakes up as steven grant on the bus the next day
he also sees khonshu again outside remember it's
just happening in his head but he also sees arthur
harrow and arthur harrow is really there following
him as we learn later when he confronts him about
his steven grant persona the joke about it being
an alias is a comic book reference because that
is the way that it started out it's just that he
slowly grew crazy over time and eventually comic
book moon i couldn't tell who the original person
was like who's the real personality and who are
the fake ones when he's confronting steven grant
he's standing next to a depiction of ammit on the
pillar next to him while they start talking about
her the reason why arthur harrow thinks that he's
a good person doing good things is because ahmed
theoretically only consumes the souls of people
who are evil doers but they're taking it to a full
minority report place in the mcu the whole plan
here that he kind of tells him in this episode
is that he wants ammit to be able to physically
enter our universe so that she'll be able to judge
everyone instantly killing everyone whoever will
do evil things and even the avengers would have
a problem with that like thanos is a really good
example star fox the other eternals didn't care
about thanos because they didn't really hate him
until he killed half the universe when arthur
harrow says her own avatar and the other egyptian
gods betrayed her she's talking about khonshu in
his other pantheon like they probably found out
what she was planning to do and then just tried
to trap her in their pocket dimension he also kind
of reveals that he's become the avatar of ammit as
well just like he is the avatar of khonshu
they make a bunch of pop culture references
they reference avatar the last airbender i can't
remember the last time i heard that reference in
a big mcu pop culture show calling it anime too
like ah remember the classic argument is avatar
the last airbender western animation actually
anime even though it's not produced inside japan
he references the live-action james cameron avatar
movies which are actually disney movies now like
fox is making avatar too but disney bought fox
so now it's a disney movie that's coming out this
december so it's a bit of a slight wink of that
too like oh by the way disney is also releasing
a giant movie this christmas the avatar movies are
back and when he tries to help him quote unquote
weighing him with his scales using the power
of ammit on him and says there's chaos in him
getting all surprised that's because when he tries
to use the power against him the scales won't stop
to give him a yes or no answer they just keep
shifting because technically marc spector has
died already the scales are only supposed to judge
people who have not died yet another great example
would be for people like vision who are artificial
people like the scales would not work on vision
when he's walking through this room he actually
walks past the statue of atum who is conscious
father in their pantheon like he has a biological
father who's more powerful than he is he also sees
a reflection of marc spector staring back at
him which stays stationary while steven grant
walks on then when he tries to escape the dog he
runs into the bathroom and in the mirrors of the
bathroom marc spector literally confronts him like
okay look steven let me explain what's going on
you're not gonna die but you gotta help me out you
gotta give me control we see what it looks like
when he slips between personalities he slips back
into the marc spector personality and we see what
it looks like when he activates his power and the
costume forms around him proceeding to beat the
crap out of the anubis dog and then they end the
episode with the shot of him walking into camera
with the full moon costume giving a good look
at it they play a bunch of egyptian inspired
theme music over the end credits as they also
depict all the egyptian gods the relevant
artifacts that he uses or going to be using during
the series all the locations that they'll visit
or we will see in flashbacks like they show
london they show the sands of egypt they show
the pyramids they show moon knight's costume
in great detail all the mummy looking cloth
wraps the doors they also depict here at the end
are also probably a representation of entering the
pocket dimension that the gods are trapped in but
there's a billion things that we could talk about
i'll try to save some of that stuff for when it
shows up in episodes and we'll just address it
as we go along episode by episode my full moon
knight episode 2 video will post next week there
are six total if that wasn't clear i'll do bonus
videos for it in between that so leave all your
requests in the comments if there's something
special about moon knight you want me to make
a video about in the next day or two everyone
click here to learn why the real gods of the
mcu like khonshu didn't stop thanos and click
here for my brand new moon knight trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!